[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ou ce nicolas et
pimprenelle sont bien bruyant ce soir je
me demande ce qui se passe ne nours le
subwoofer
patron je m'en vais voir ce web plus
preuve je te fais confiance fidèle
compagnon vas-y vite ou le schème promet
tu as pris mon verre dans nicolas si je
ne trouve pas mon vin c'est parce que
c'est toi qui m'as pris non
celui-ci l'hérault alors c'est mieux non
le tiens il est bleu la fille qui se
passe il trouve passe au vert alors il
fait problème vient d'avoir une est à
moi voyons le zoo au cet ensemble
nicolas voit la loutre verts n'ont plus
beau promettre qu'il a c'est une vilaine
par ronald fait une onde oui
[Musique]
le citron salle maison je jouerai plus
avec cette petite soeur qu'elle est
seule à l'eau au nom de nom du pape
rhône éléments d'un moment oui mais pas
vincent moment du colloque a tort de
dire ça on t'aime
nous c'est très vilain se mettre au
collège il ne faut jamais se mettre en
colère
oui maintenant prenait elle à son verre
et toi le tient à l'eau tu embrasses ta
soeur et tu vas où lee alors prenez vous
à nicolas tient tête à manger
bonsoir mais non seulement à condition
que vous vous disputiez je recommencerai
plein ours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je très bien comme ça bogny lezons en
pleine nuit nyalas là j'ai gagné de
[Musique]
ratoma
tu sais je recommencerai plus menue
pimprenelle bonne nuit nicolas d'or biya
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très vilain de se mettre en colère
ce pauvre petit nicolas il doit être
bien triste se finit patron je fus du ne
recommencera plus il me la prend dans
mieux mon gros nounours
alors en route bonne nuit des enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents allaient
sagement vous coucher et faites de beaux
rêves à 2 pour à demain 2
mon
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]